♪ ♪
>> Greg: "THE BACHELOR" FINALE
WAS LAST NIGHT.
HERE IS THE HIGH POINT.
>> WE JUST MADE A BIG CIRCLE.
IT'S A TRASH FIRE.
>> Greg: THAT IT IS, IT'S A
TRASH FIRE.
IT BOILED DOWN TO A CAD
PROPOSING TO A WOMAN HE HAD
PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED TO AND
DUMPED AND HUMILIATED ON LIVE
TELEVISION, A DIFFERENT GAL.
YES, I SAID GAL.
>> THE BEST DECISION WAS RUNNING
BACK TO YOU.
WILL YOU MARRY ME?
>> DEFINITELY.
>> Greg: THAT IS A MISTAKE.
THE SECOND WOMAN ACCEPTED THE
PROPOSAL FROM THIS SNORE OF A
BORE.
YOU KNOW LOVE CONQUERS ALL
ESPECIALLY WHEN A PRODUCER
DEMANDS IT.
THE DUMPED WOMAN CONFRONTED THE
JERK ABOUT HIS DECEITFUL
CHARACTER AND HE APOLOGIZED.
SHE FORGAVE HIM.
ARIE USED MODERN THERAPY SPEAK
TO PAPER OVER HIS ACTIONS.
THE WOMAN IS STILL HURT BUT HE
FEELS HER PAIN.
>> I DO REGRET PROPOSING THAT
DAY BECAUSE I WASN'T FULLY
READY.
>> WHY DID YOU?
>> I THINK THE PRESSURE OF THIS.
THE PRESSURE OF BEING THE
BACHELOR, KNOWING THERE'S A
TIMELINE AND HAVING TO MAKE THE
DECISION ON THAT DAY.
>> YOU ALWAYS HAVE A CHOICE AND
THEY DIDN'T NEED TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE.
>> I KNOW, AND I OWN UP TO THAT.
THAT'S ON ME.
TOTALLY ON ME.
I HAVE NO EXCUSE FOR THAT.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
>> I FORGIVE YOU.
>> Greg: THAT WAS FAST.
>> Kimberly: THAT WAS A LITTLE
SCRIPTED.
>> Greg: SORRY, LADIES, HE'S
TAKEN.
SO DID BECCA LEARN HER LESSON
THAT SEEKING LOVE ON THE REALITY
SHOW OFTEN DOESN'T PAN OUT THE
WAY YOU EXPECT.
SHE AGREED TO BE THE
BACHELORETTE IN THE NEXT SERIES.
A SHOW HUMILIATES YOU AND YOUR
SOLUTION: RETURN TO THE VERY
SHOW THAT HUMILIATES YOU.
IT IS LIKE NEON "THE FIVE."
>> Kimberly: YOU LOVE IT.
>> Greg: THEY PARADED ALL THE
NEW MAIL FLASH -- HOW QUICKLY
ARIE THE CREEP WAS TOSSED ON THE
HEAP.
ONE MAN SHOWED UP.
WHO NEEDS A ASS WHEN YOU CAN
HAVE A HORSE.